varazdat is a veteran from armenia's
recent war with azerbaijan he is
adjusting to his new life
a life without arms varazdat lost his
arms
rescuing his own brother who'd been
wounded in the leg
it's almost too much for their mother
lyanna to remember that day
varazdat was with his brother in the
ambulance when the shell struck
despite his pain my brother came to help
me
the medic and driver were also wounded
the interior was on fire the mattresses
were burning
but we drove on while my brother tried
to put out the fire
officially 94 armenian soldiers were
wounded in the six-week war over
nagorno-karabakh
dr pagosian treats some of the most
seriously injured
at this rehabilitation center in
you never get used to all of this it's
very difficult to see these young
soldiers
and many of them are helpless as a
doctor
it's terribly difficult for me to tell
some of them that they will never walk
again
that burden is on me
physiotherapy and dry needling is
helping
hike stephanian with the pain in his
stumps
he tells me the prospect of returning to
sport
keeps him motivated hike is
one of 300 patients at this center
receiving therapy therapy that wouldn't
be possible without the support of
charitable funding because the state
here is simply
not in a position to cope with the sheer
scale
of the problem it looks a little bit too
short the centre will soon have a
prosthetics workshop paid for by a dutch
armenian charity
there are a lot of amputated people
they are waiting for prosthesis in a
short time
that's a big challenge but i think it's
a big plus
that they are generally healthy and
they are very motivated to to work with
prosthesis
armenian taxpayers also make mandatory
payments into a soldiers insurance fund
but varesdad needs advanced prosthetics
costing tens of thousands of euros the
kind that would enable him to hold his
own cup of coffee again
they've told us this kind of prosthesis
is beyond our reach
maybe this is a huge amount of money and
people like us can't afford these types
of artificial limbs
but what does that say about us if we
can't afford it
who can if the homeland was worth
sacrificing my arms for
why should new ones be beyond my reach
varesdad hasn't wasted time since his
injuries
he got engaged to his girlfriend
there's still hope that he will live an
independent life
again robin forest dear walker al
jazeera yerevan